فيما يخص تصريحات في ستوكهولم لدى لقائه
بوزراء دفاع الدول الاوروبيه لم تذهب
بعيدا ايضا عن تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
يعني كانت قبل يومين حول ضخمه يبدو ان
شركائك ايف ينظرون الى ان باك مت وكانوا
قد نصحوا طبعا كيف من قبل بالانسحاب من
هذه المدينه ولكن القياده العسكريه
والسياسيه في اوكرانيا ترى ان هذا هدف
استراتيجي بالنسبه لها وانها لن تنسحب من
هذه المدينه طبعا كانوا قد برروا ذلك
بكلفه الباهظه
للتمسك بالمدينه في الزخائر وايضا في
القوات يعني الجميع هناك يفقد اعداد كبيره
من الجنود وكذلك تصرف اوكرانيا عدد هائل
من الذقائر حتى الان لم تعلق القياده
الاوكرانيه حول هذه التصريحات ولكن بشكل
عام اوكرانيا متمسكه بالبقاء في باخ وتنظر
اليه كهدف استراتيجي سوف تواصل عمليه
الدفاع عن مدينه باقمت طبعا بالفعل قامت
بتعزيز دفاعاتها الهندسيه غرب المدينه
وجهزت نفسها لعمليه انسحاب محتمله
كوضع يمكن ان تجد نفسها في لذلك قامت
بالتجهيز المبكر لذلك حتى لا تفتح الطريق
لمواصله القوات الروسيه الزحف نحو مدن
كبيره واساسيه في نتحدث عن كراماتورسكو عن
سلافانسكو وايضا كاستانتين وعدد من المدن
الصغيره في الاقليم وهذا طبعا ايضا هو هدف
اساسي بالنسبه للاتحاد الروسي الان هو
الاستيلاء والسيطره على كامل الحدود
الاداريه